there's one word that sums up how we've
gotten to this insane pass and it's
cowardice the number one ingredient that
if it were present would change the
outcome of almost all of these stories
all of the smearing of good people for
maybe a worse making a mistake
is is courage it's a story of cowardice
and courage the moment that we're in
from 2017 to 2020 she was an opinion
writer for the new york times then in a
very public resignation she torched the
work culture there and revealed the
tense radical environment she was
working within before our guest barry
weiss was at the time she was at the
wall street journal for five years
and now stepping away from the biggest
news outlet in the country she's in the
midst of crafting her own media property
she now releases common sense with barry
weiss a newsletter on substat with the
freedom to investigate and pursue
stories she simply didn't have before
she recently launched her own podcast as
well honestly with barry weiss featuring
unique and captivating conversations and
stories rooted in the most fundamental
issues the country and all of us are up
against right now
barry wrote about and popularized the
intellectual dark web at the new york
times back in 2018 it was at that time
that we connected we've been friends
since and in this episode we talk about
why she's been avoiding joining my show
these past three years
plus in our conversation barry talks
about how the 2016 election landed her
at the new york times the first
experience she had being virally
attacked across the internet and media
and some ideas to preserve the middle
where most americans are politically
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn protect your
data from bigtech with the vpni trust
visit expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with barry
the only way to get access to that part
of the conversation is to become a
member head on over to dailywire.com
become a member you'll have access to
all of the full conversations with every
one of our awesome guests barry weiss
thanks so much for joining the show i'm
really happy to be here finally left the
new york times so i could come here uh
as a safe space right just for that just
for that so so let's talk about you know
how you got involved with the new york
times i want to go through kind of your
whole evolution here because i i first
got to know you when you were still
writing at the new york times and you
were doing a big story on the the
so-called intellectual dark web which
has gone through some iterations at this
point but you were writing for the new
york times and how did you get that gig
what was the sort of idea going in there
yeah so i had been at the wall street
journal editorial page where i was the
resident squish i was the most sort of
left-leaning person and otherwise as
your audience will no conservative
editorial page
then came trump and the very same sort
of
civil war cold civil war that happened
in the conservative movement happened in
the republican party happened inside the
wall street journal editorial page i
very much found myself on the never
trump side of things along with brett
stevens and a number of my other
colleagues and after his nomination and
his eventual win
a lot of us were sort of looking for a
new home at the very same time the new
york times was sort of looking in the
mirror this lasted only a very brief
time
but
for a little bit of time there was they
were engaged in a period of
self-reflection everyone will remember
the night before trump's win in 2016
that the infamous needle had hillary
clinton winning by a margin of 99 or
whatever it was and then all of a sudden
lo and behold donald trump won and the
new york times which prides itself or at
least ostensibly on being the paper of
record on being able to hold up a mirror
to the country in the world as it
actually is
thought to themselves how did we get it
so wrong
and i was brought in to be blunt as an
intellectual diversity hire
my
specific explicit job was to be an op-ed
editor that would bring in pieces from
people that wouldn't otherwise think of
the new york times as a natural home for
them to publish so that meant
conservatives it meant libertarians it
meant heterodox thinkers it meant and
this is a particular passion of mine
dissidents throughout the arab world
christians in hong kong
people who have english as a second
language that's the kind of bread and
butter
work i had always done at the wall
street journal
and so that's how i arrived that's how
brett stevens arrived and then things
sort of took a turn so let's talk about
kind of why things went sour because
that was something that i observed as
well and you could see it kind of
throughout the left and when trump won
there was a moment of shocking
realization that maybe we don't know all
the things there are to know because
after 2012 there was sort of this
impression that democrats were going to
win from now on to forever because
barack obama had forged this brand new
coalition the kind of coalition of the
dispossessed we're now going to
overwhelm american politics and so
there's no need to worry about those
white people out in the sticks anymore
and so we're just going to ignore those
people we're instead going to focus in
on this coterie and then trump wins and
so the idea was suddenly it dawned on
them that
there there needed to be some
investigation of what happened but the
way that they seemed to investigate it
was it was sort of like steve irwin
going out into the wild they would send
some guy with like an australian outfit
out to some diner in ohio and they'd be
like what are what did the locals think
right and what was so astonishing is one
of the only people i personally knew
that called the election or that told me
she really really suspected trump would
win was my mom why because i'm from
pittsburgh and my mom at the time had a
flooring business that took her to you
know driving an hour two hours outside
of pittsburgh you know into you know
pennsyltucky as people call it and she
would call me and say barry i've never
seen anything like this it's like the
side of barns are made with homemade
signs for this guy like i'm telling you
you guys are crazy this guy you know the
times is crazy this guy has momentum
that you just can't isn't being captured
in the mainstream press so that was my
mom you know someone without any
expertise none of the tools that nate
silver has at his disposal i went to the
times
not naive
i'm from you know a zionist jewish
family i had seen the bias that the new
york times had toward israel for my
entire life my dad's a political
conservative my mom's a liberal we the
new york times was and its bias was a
topic of incredible and sustained
discussion in my house from the time
that i was young
what i didn't expect was the sort of
lack of collegiality that was there
almost from the beginning and then
really really really grew and also the
sense and this of course you know burst
into public view with the decision to
publish this op-ed by senator tom cotton
last june um in our sort of fevered
summer of of covid and george floyd's
killing and the rest that people
genuinely believed that ideas that they
disagreed with were literal violence and
harm
that's what i didn't expect did i expect
that you know conservative ideas or you
know non-progressive ideas would be
written off as sort of backward in
retrograde of course did i expect that
there would be biases on any number of
issues not least of which israel a sort
of bias let's say against american power
of course what i did not expect was the
idea that that
being exposed to those ideas and
exposing our readers to those ideas was
actually violence was actually putting
people's literal lives in danger
that's when i realized you know andrew
sullivan's put it better than anyone we
all live on campus now and
you know i was a student at columbia 15
years ago that was sort of my original
sort of waking up moment to the excesses
of the liberal left
long story short you know i found myself
sort of being called a conservative and
a you know a zio nazi and a neocon when
i was very much a progressive and and
that's when i sort of started to witness
this the nature of this ideology
what i didn't expect and what i think
no one fully expected was the extent to
which
that ideology would come to swallow
all of the sense-making institutions of
american life
all of the institutions that are charged
with upholding our liberal order and i
mean that in the most capacious sense of
the word you know our publishing houses
our newspapers our magazines our
universities our movie studios as you
know a lot of our tech companies and
increasingly corporate america that's i
think what
many people didn't expect and all of
these ideas were treated as a kind of
punchline and then all of a sudden
you're sitting there at the most
important newspaper in the world whether
or not you would you know whether or not
you read it whether or not you subscribe
it is the most important newspaper in
the world and it's supposed to you know
it has a job which is to be the paper of
record and instead of you know instead
of abiding by its motto which is all the
news that's fit to print it's no it's
all the news that fits the narrative
it's all the news that advances our
political agenda so anything that
doesn't is either ignored it's
overlooked it's neutered it's papered
over and that was something that was
obvious to me within the first year that
i was there um but it really just got
progressively more intense i would say
so i guess what i was going to ask is
when was that when was like kind of that
first moment where you realized that
they were going to try and buy this back
where there was that moment where they
were like okay we're going to try and
give some sort of credibility or at
least try to make sense of these people
we don't understand and then it went to
principal skinner it's not us wrong it's
the children who are wrong when did that
first kick in for you god there were a
few sort of
signal moments signal events
one of them that i remember really
clearly has been i'm sure you'll you'll
remember that there was hanukkah i think
it was hanukkah of 2019 that was there
was an attack a violent attack against
jews almost every single day of that
holiday there was the machete attack
upstate in muncie new york where a
rabbi's home was invaded by a guy with
giant machete tried to kill as many
people as he could ended up murdering a
guy named joseph newman there was the
attack um in on the new jersey kosher
supermarket that was carried out by
acolytes of the black hebrew israelites
which are not hebrew israelites but are
just sort of like a hate group nation of
islam farrakhan kind of vibe and anyway
i wrote a piece at the time a column
called america's bloody hanukkah or
america's bloody program and i thought
it was a really good column it was the
you know it was really my subject i mean
i'd written a book called how to fight
anti-semitism i was bought mitzvahed at
the synagogue in pittsburgh tree of life
where the most lethal attack against
american jews in all american history
was carried out i have some skin in the
game and i know a lot about this subject
and i was basically called into my
editor's office and was told we can't
really run this and the reason in the
end of the day why we couldn't really
run it is that the people that were
carrying out the attacks weren't
white supremacists carrying tiki torches
um
when when the person carrying out the
attack against jews is a white
supremacist is a neo-nazi there's
incredible moral clarity but because of
this the nature of this ideology when an
anti-semite comes from a group that has
been deemed you know fundamentally
oppressed no matter what
then all of a sudden it's morally
confusing in this ideology when that
person is also happens to be a
victimizer and so that was a moment for
me where i thought to myself
hold on like this is news this is
important i am an expert in this subject
and i'm being told that it doesn't have
a place in the times and then i found
and and this this is the really
insidious nature of it
ideas and op-eds
and columns that i would write that sort
of suited the narrative
those went right into the paper
the amount of
energy
and sort of
diplomacy and political capital that you
needed to sort of smuggle through pieces
that didn't suit the ideology
it just took so much work
and this was the part that i found that
i was found myself um this was the trap
i found myself falling into that you
thought yourself out of commissioning
those pieces to begin with and i thought
to myself
this is like
not why i became a journalist i became a
journalist to pursue my curiosity i
became a journalist to hear the ideas of
people that i don't always agree with i
became a journalist because i want to
expose readers to things that are
provocative or surprising or
serendipitous
and it just became
deadening and it became really boring
and then of course tom cotton happened
so let's talk in just a second about
what actually triggered you to leave
because that was a bit of a process in
and of itself first let's talk about
your investment strategy if you had one
billion dollars what would you do spend
500 million bucks on a yacht like a tech
billionaire or take a rocket ship to
space for four minutes how about buying
a ticket to the world's most expensive
dinner and then railing against the rich
like aoc well nothing makes me happier
than to tell you i wouldn't do any of
those things if i were a billionaire i'd
only put my money into things i actually
believe in there is an asset that i've
had my eye on for a while i could never
own it it's called blue chip art now
seriously i do invest in art a year ago
you'd need tens of millions of dollars
or you'd get laughed out of the building
all of that has changed with masterworks
dot io they're destroying the status quo
of all the people in their little
country clubs who think art and culture
should only belong to the trust fund
brigade masterworks dot io is the first
company to crack open the exclusive six
trillion dollar art world so every man
woman and child in america can finally
get a piece of that particular pie after
all there's nothing more patriotic than
taking something made for the kings and
queens and giving it to the people with
biden casually writing three trillion
dollar checks from his basement it's
definitely an alternative asset worth
considering right now masterworks.io has
democratized more than 250 million
dollars worth of art away from the ultra
rich and placed it into the pockets of
the populace so join over 200 000
members many of whom are ben shapiro
listeners and skip to the front of the
waitlist with my unique link go to
masterworks dot io slash ben that's
masterworks dot io slash ben before
deciding to invest carefully review the
important disclosures at masterworks dot
io disclaimer okay so over this course
of time you're increasingly under
pressure my first experience actually
speaking with you was right after that
idw piece i think we talked for the the
idw piece and i remember you got an
enormous blowback for the for the idw
piece as well and to me that was kind of
my first inkling even then i think that
what was that 2018 maybe yeah and there
had been like a viral tweet where i was
trying to
praise immigrants and
you know and i i i quoted a line from
hamilton and i was describing a figure
it's not even worth getting into it i
remember i remember it's so absurd it
was ridiculous but
i you know and i have a very long
history of writing pieces in favor of
immigration and yet you know this caused
such consternation at the new york times
that when i went on bill maher a week or
a week later the times pressured me and
i was expected to and i did explain the
tweet and essentially apologize for it
this is over a tweet yep you know so if
if that
amount of risk you know
generates that kind of stress level i
remember that they were parroting you on
snl you were trending on twitter like
basically you had my record on twitter
you were you were being trended every
couple of weeks now i'm used to it but
at the time and i think anyone who's
sort of emerging
as a is someone in the public square in
any way will admit
it flattened me
it flattened me i mean it was i was at a
family wedding that weekend and all of a
sudden all of these people
you know who were i thought ostensibly
were my colleagues both literal
employees of the new york times but also
broader you know journalists who i knew
were
pouncing on me and were calling me you
know xenophobic they were calling me a
bigot they were calling me they're
calling me everything that i hate
and it's very painful and that's that's
the thing about
this
trend and this culture and this movement
that is so terrible is that it
weaponizes empathy like it and it makes
you you know one of the things that i
think is really important as
writers and journalists and you know
intellectuals to the extent that i am
one is being able to change your mind
and to be able to change your mind you
need to be able to hear criticism but
when that criticism is coming in such
bad faith it almost makes you want to
sort of build a fortress around yourself
which is a terrible thing if you're
trying to be able to be someone that is
open-minded and here's criticism in good
faith if that makes sense no it makes so
much sense i mean i've had this
experience personally many many times
where if you're a good hearted person
forget about being a journalist if
you're a good hearted person you want to
make your self better in any way you
have to have some sort of feedback
mechanism where somebody can tell you
you're doing something wrong and keep
you within the lanes of of doing the
right thing and when that feedback
mechanism gets hijacked by people who
despise you and they just start giving
you bad feedback that is designed to
tearing you down the natural instinct is
to create a bubble and an echo chamber
and so the question is how do you create
a life where you can receive the
feedback that's necessary but sort of
prevent the feedback that is badly
motivated
and prevent and i think that we could
both think of examples in mind but
prevent the kind of
radicalization and hardening that comes
from getting that bad feedback and i
think i've been able to do it pretty
well but that's just a risk that comes
with sort of being in the public square
and getting that kind of
you know negative and irrational and
nonsensical often feedback and that was
really that tweet was the first time
that it happened to me and one of the
things that was very difficult about it
is that i didn't really understand the
kind of support structure that i needed
yet and i also was getting that feedback
from people that were setting two desks
away from me
and that's really really
difficult it's hard to work in an
environment where you have a
conversation it's an open newsroom and
then you hear that the conversation you
had on your phone in what's supposed to
be a news room is getting repeated as
you know cocktail party fodder and that
you know makes you paranoid and it makes
you just unable to take the kind of risk
that i want to be able to do and that
since i've left i've really been able to
do again so finally you make the
decision that you want to leave yeah you
write this this very widely trafficked
letter it's a terrific letter about the
the shortcomings of the new york times i
think i read it in its entirety on the
air uh the the the letter discusses all
the problems with the closing of the
mind at the new york times and it also
discusses the fact that the higher ups
at the new york times stood for this and
that that really is the big question to
me is not the fact that you have
schmucks working at the new york times
it's the the the leaders at these
institutions have become such
unbelievable cowards and this is true at
virtually every major institution in the
country that they are allowing the
insane to run the asylum the people who
are in charge of the new york times are
not the heads of the new york times they
are the woke wing of the new york times
you get to dictate what the coverage
looks like there's one word that sums up
how we've gotten to this insane pass and
it's cowardice there's a million other
words that we can use to describe how
we've gotten here the number one
ingredient that if it were present would
change the outcome of almost all of
these stories
all of these cancellations all of the
hijacking of these institutions all of
the smearing of good people for maybe at
worst making a mistake
is is courage it's a story of cowardice
and courage the moment that we're in and
what has been astonishing to me
is to find you know to look around and
see wait hold on you're supposed to be
the adult in the room you're the person
that is being charged with upholding the
mission of these institutions i'm
thinking now about the times but also i
could be thinking about any number of
universities or any of the other
institutions that we mentioned before
the amount of work that it takes to
build up that kind of cultural capital
that kind of trust with your audience or
with the public i mean that is work that
takes decades and centuries we have seen
in the case of the new york times that
it takes
really a couple years to just
fundamentally trash it and destroy it
and
the fact that they are sort of making
this um
bad bet where they somehow believe that
by acquiescing or negotiating with this
illiberal faction and it's illiberal
inside of the institution that they will
somehow be able to preserve the
institutions exactly the wrong thing
when the times decided to run the tom
cotton op-ed there was something like
800 of my colleagues who signed a letter
saying that this op-ed by a sitting you
know united states senator literally put
their lives in danger
if you're running the new york times you
know what you need to say to those
people
if you believe that a 900 word op-ed
puts your life in danger then maybe
journalism is not the right line of work
for you and you should and certainly not
the new york times and you should seek
employment elsewhere do you know how
many unemployed journalists there are in
this country right now with every single
almost local newspaper being swallowed
up or destroyed how many you know
blue-collar journalists there are who
would be fantastic in the new york times
because the idea that you need an ivy
league degree or college degree at all
to go and ask people questions which is
what journalism is about you know you
could have filled the newsroom 10 times
over but instead they acquiesce to it
because it turns out they're more scared
of being called an ism or a phobe or
whatever in public
than they are of you know
doing the work of preserving their
institution and one of the things that
that obviously has happened here is not
only that they are afraid of being
called those things but they're afraid
of being associated with anybody who
might be called those things right so i
was recently at a kind of a hoity-toity
event i only do a couple of these a year
and it was a bunch of people with whom i
disagree on politics and there was a big
discussion of political polarization and
they came to me and i said if you want
to end political polarization take a
picture of me right now and post it on
the internet that's exactly what i said
i said if you want to end political
polarization all you have to do it
doesn't have to be me but what you need
to do these are all people big twitter
followings is go on twitter find
somebody who didn't vote like you in the
last election cycle say this is a nice
person i enjoy having dinner with them
and their ideas are worth listening to
even if i disagree that's all you have
to do and political polarization will be
over not one person did it obviously of
course because the the amount of fear
out there is just astonishing and what's
amazing fear is justified that's what's
so sad about where we are meaning
you know one of the reasons that i've
hesitated to come on your show or
hesitated to do other shows is like
first of all is it worth the headache
that it's gonna take for the next you
know month of my life that i'm sure i'm
gonna get online but also you know
what's what's in the balance for a lot
of these people
especially the ones who are still
working inside of these institutions is
you know am i going to lose my job am i
going to lose my reputation am i going
to lose my children's reputation is my
kid going to be bullied at school or
soccer practice like crowd-sourced
mccarthyism actually works you know the
new the recent cato study had something
like 62 percent of americans were
unwilling to voice their true views out
loud
that's the thing that i think is like
really fascinating about the moment that
we're in
we believed or at least i believed
studying history that this kind of
behavior and this kind of fear and this
kind of double speak was only possible
under a stalin or a mao
but it turns out that's not true you can
do it in a crowd-sourced way fueled by
big tech and big social and this is
where we've ended up the the astonishing
thing and the thing i think we both
realize is that
you know if
a thousand people stood up
a thousand people and did exactly what
you're describing the whole country
would be different
it is an amazing thing and the
unwillingness of people to do it as you
say is it is both justified and also
amazing in a second i want to ask you
about whether you think that there is
that sort of stomach and spine in what i
think is sort of the
classical liberal center to actually
save the countries i actually think that
the the future of the country does not
rest with conservatives or people on the
left i think it actually rests with the
people in the middle and which way
they're going to go i'll explain in a
second first let's talk about your need
for life insurance if somebody relies on
your financial support whether it's a
kid or an aging parent or even a
business partner you need life insurance
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare we could
say 50 or more in life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could save 1300 bucks or more per year
on life insurance by using policy genius
to compare policies the licensed experts
at policy genius work for you not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and buying process that
kind of service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google and eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week thanks to an award-winning
policy option that swaps the standard
medical exam requirement for a simple
phone call this exclusive policy was
recently rated number one by forbes
advisor higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
simple first head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price and then when you're
ready to apply the policy genius team
will handle the paperwork and the
scheduling for free policy genius
doesn't add on extra fees head on over
to policygenius.com shapiro to get
started right now policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and very
important to get it right
so here is my going theory so the
harper's weekly letter comes out
sometime last year and it basically
suggests canceled culture is bad and
what i said at the time is i noticed
that there wasn't a single person who
actually was a signatory to the harper's
weekly letter who had publicly voted for
trump uh there wasn't a single person
who said that they were intending on
voting for trump i don't think there was
a single person that identified as a
conservative that's right uh there there
might have been a couple of people who
maybe tangentially were connected with
conservatism but not really so much and
so i think i barely made the cut is the
point that's right i would qualify as a
conservative so my big question about
the harper's weekly letter and it's my
question for for sort of the people who
consider themselves politically centered
but also in favor of individual rights
is whether the attempt is to open the
overton window just enough so that they
themselves can sneak through or is the
attempt to open the overton window broad
enough that we can actually have a
conversation that's an actual real
question because it seems to me that
there are a lot of people who are you
know classically liberal encompasses a
couple different definitions one is the
classical liberal economic fair which i
don't know that everybody who we are now
categorizing as liberal is in that
category then there is the the sort of
broader liberal rubric of individual
rights post enlightenment and there
those are the people i think we're
talking about the question is for those
folks who actually agree politically
with a lot of the policy agenda of left
but disagree with their agenda on
individual rights are they willing to
make the sacrifice of putting off utopia
in order to preserve the individual
rights or are they just going to say you
know what
screw the individual rights for the
moment we need to be fellow travelers
with the people who are going to get us
where we need to go in terms of
more even redistribution of wealth or in
terms of more redistributive means of of
racial reparations
where do you think that movement is do
you think there are enough of people you
know who are like you or andrew sullivan
or do you think that it's going to trend
more toward you know what we've seen
from some outlets like the atlantic
where if you differ the overton window
is only open just this far past hillary
clinton maybe
i think the question is you know someone
joked the other day that a lot of these
people have a rule and the rule is no
friends to the right of me you know no
associations to the right of me that's a
really good litmus test are you willing
to be associated with people who are
conservative are you willing to see
the truth right now which is that we're
living through this massive political
realignment
one in which you know you sometimes
sound more liberal than a lot of the
people who are like to the right you
know everything feels like it's sort of
thrown up in the air and the question is
do you have the intestinal fortitude you
know to say you know what this person is
to the right of me this person right now
you know like i'm sure you disapprove of
my marriage to a woman i know we
disagree on abortion i know we disagree
on any number of things and you know
what i don't care and the reason i don't
care is because i really feel like we
are in a fundamental war to preserve the
bedrock of liberalism to preserve the
thing that allows us to sit here and
have this conversation without ripping
each other's heads off that's what's at
stake and i think for those who are able
to see that that's what's at stake yes
they will have that sort of spine and
fortitude and all of the other metaphors
that we could come up with the question
as you put it is how many are there
right how many are there i really really
believe that the self-silencing majority
of this country is broadly
in the center wants a different choice
other than laura ingraham and rachel
maddow at night but because of a million
reasons we could point to including
polarization including the incentives of
cable news including the incentives of
you know big tech wanting to keep us
enraged so we stay online and on and on
and on and because of cancel culture
these people are quiet these are the
people that you know are dissidents in
some of the most liberal institutions in
the country the people that write me
these are people who say to me you know
i don't know where to go where i don't
fit in anymore i'm homeless
those are the people that i am trying to
speak to those are the people who i
believe are the majority and those are
the people i agree with you ben whether
or not america is able to preserve
itself as a liberal democracy really
depends on those people standing up and
speaking out right now yeah i mean i i
think the big question that i keep
having and it's to people on the left
and to people on the right is whether we
want to share our country anymore if the
question is whether we want to share our
country anymore i think that as we
nationalize every single issue is every
issue the way we think about politics is
not local no it's all flattened it's all
one big national story and everything is
seen through that lens exactly it's all
no one cares what state governments do
anymore unless it becomes a federal
issue but it's all what the federal
government does or what you're seeing on
national media or what you are seeing in
terms of social media where what
somebody is doing in new york affects me
in florida because it's on social media
because of that great flattening effect
that you're talking about it's actually
resulting in not people combining or
people actually making connections it's
resulting in precisely the opposite
you're actually starting to see this
massive self-sorting effect i mean
listen i'm part of it i left california
because of this right we moved down to
florida because i didn't want to live in
california anymore and i think you're
going to start to see more and more of
that and so the question is going to
become if we actually want to share a
country together we are going to have to
have a lighter hand when it comes to
what happens at the very top level and
then say that we're going to have to
leave each other alone closer to the
bottom level or there isn't going to be
a country anymore i agree with that i
also think and i i think we're starting
to see the seeds of
maybe the backlash in a positive way
there's some scarier backlash we can
talk about but a backlash to the sort of
nationalization flattening effect of
everything and the online ification of
everything there's
a movement i think a foot in this
country that wants to say you know what
it really matters who my neighbors are
and it really matters that i'm connected
to people and you know like you know
public safety in my neighborhood is the
thing that actually matters to me and
feeling connected to people that you're
surrounded by the other thing that i've
noticed that blew my mind there was a
statistic that came out the other day
something like you know 50 of
millennials did you see this pray to god
every day identify it's it's
mind-blowing and i don't know i just
think that people are sick of the way
that we're living it's literally making
people sick and i think that a backlash
to that is coming now whether or not
that backlash looks like something
that's healthy that's focused on
people's communities that's focused on
local life that's focused on reviving
civic and religious organizations that's
one way we can go the other really scary
way we can go and this is one of the
reasons that i've been so outspoken
about woke ideology is a world in which
everything is seen through the lens of
race everyone becomes hyper racialized
and that can lead to a very scary
backlash that we were talking about
before the show in which you know if you
tell 10 year old boys that your
whiteness is the thing that really
matters to you your whiteness gives you
a lot of power
i don't want to live in a country where
that is the idea that's given to young
children you know from the time that
they're little kids that their race is
the thing that matters to them it's the
thing that matters more than anything
else and in fact it gives them
tremendous power that's very scary to me
so this is some of the stuff that you've
been writing about at your sub stack
which is now wildly popular and thank
god it proves that there's a market for
the kind of stuff that you actually want
to get out there the the i'll say
disintegration of centralized media has
had a lot of beneficial side effects i
think so and your sub stack is part of
that obviously daily wire is part of
that people can get their news from a
bunch of different sources which is
something i highly recommend you've been
writing a lot about the takeover of
particularly lower levels of schooling
by sort of woke intersectional ideology
and exactly the sort of self-silencing
effect that we've been discussing and
you see it at private schools across the
country you see it certainly public
schools across the country parents who
are afraid of going up against their
peers even though their peers probably
agree with them the idea is that if you
keep enough people silent they can never
actually unionize they can never
actually get together and say yeah what
they're doing at school is bad you just
shut them up and then you never have to
worry about if you're the administration
right this is a good moment where people
should take lessons from the left about
solidarity and collective action one of
the things that's sort of blown my mind
as i've reported on these stories in
public schools in private schools in
blue states and red it's everywhere now
is
how insulated people are from each other
so a parent will come to me and say
don't say i say anything another parent
will come to me don't say i said
anything and then i'll hear from a
teacher and i'm like
you guys realize that
most of the people agree with you but
they've been so scared to even voice
their opposition to this even behind
closed doors even to other parents that
they really don't know any better and
one of the main things that i tell
parents that are concerned about the
direction of their school is collective
action solidarity find other people that
agree with you you will be so much more
effective in standing up to this one of
the most you know unbelievable examples
of it has played out in lounge county
virginia where parents like asura numani
and zivan fleet who survived mao's
culture revolution in china you know
and on and on and on mostly minority
parents have been standing up to the
school board there and it's been an
incredible example to watch you know we
were talking before about cowardice and
courage i think one of the things that's
been really inspiring to me and also
surprising about the moment that we're
living in is that you would think that
courage would come from the people that
have sort of accrued
capital that have reached the pinnacle
of their careers but it's the opposite
courage is coming from the periphery
courage is coming from people like
there's this amazing mom gabby clark in
nevada you know whose son william was a
student at a democracy prep there and he
was forced like kids in so many schools
these days to you know publicly
self-identify his race and his gender
and his sexual orientation and then to
attach negative labels to them if they
were negative like white or male and
william's biracial and he refused to do
it and they they failed him and most
parents in that situation would say to
their kid and say in you know maybe
their family meeting
let's just move on let's get you into
good college forget about them and gabby
clark decided to sue the school and sue
based on her child's first amendment
rights and other constitutional rights
and when i called her to ask her where
she got this cur the courage to do it
she was completely baffled by the
question
she said to me what are you talking
about
this is this is wrong and i'm just
standing up for what's right and every
single parent should be doing the same
for their kid that's it that's kind of
it you know like now is the moment you
know you saw in peter burgosian's in a
resignation letter to portland state
university where he'd been trying for
the past decade to stand up for
liberalism and he wrote in the end of
his letter which we published on my sub
stack you know i've been teaching my
students for 10 years that one of the
things that i am obligated to do and
we're all obligated to do as liberals
and americans is to defend liberalism
who would i be if i didn't who would i
be if i capitulated to this and that's
the question i think should be ringing
in everyone's ears right now
think about how hard it is right now
for you or for anyone to stand up
against this where are we going to be as
a country 5 10 20 years from now if we
don't stand up it's only going to get
harder it's only going to get harder
it's the easiest that it's going to be
is in this very moment and i think it's
really important for us to do it right
now so one of the things that you've
written a lot about obviously and that
you had to deal with at the new york
times is the intersectional coalition
this idea of intersectionality as a
philosophy not the sort of game playing
where we go back to kimberly crenshaw's
original legal article and we discuss
how if you fit more than one box maybe
you're discriminated against in a
variety of ways but which is true
of course of course it's true of course
it's true but the the basic idea was
then expanded out to essentially suggest
that there is a hierarchy of
victimization in the united states and
that depending where you are on the
hierarchy of victimization you are no
longer capable of causing offense and
also if somebody is less victimized than
you then you are free to do or say about
them pretty much yeah it's i think their
4am has been replaced with you know i am
this identity therefore i am right or i
am therefore i have a greater claim to
truth or morality
that's what's so
you know malicious about this idea so
how did this kind of slay traditional
left-wing thought traditional liberalism
because there
there was a pretty large scale conflict
over this i mean this sort of racial
radicalism was tried and found wanting
by the democratic party in large part in
the early 1970s for example with george
mcgovern who promoted some of this sort
of stuff
you saw it with with attempts in the
1980s by some of the democrats and that
was pretty much rejected i mean bill
clinton in 1992 literally had a sister
soldier moment in which people who were
promoting this sort of ideology were
called out on the campaign trail by the
leading democratic contender for the
presidency and it went away for a while
and then it came back with a vengeance
and and it seems like there's almost no
systemic immunity on the left due to
this sort of ideology why do you think
so i mean frankly i think that barack
obama's elevation to the presidency in
2009 and his shift from who he
campaigned as in 2008 to what he became
in his second term
was pretty dramatic so in 2008
my theory goes he campaigned as the guy
he was at the 2004 democratic national
convention no red states no blue states
we're all the united states no white no
black we're all we're all just americans
and then he won and after he won this
broad sweeping victory with huge levels
of popularity then he was faced with
what all presidents are faced with a lot
of people who didn't like his agenda and
instead of him saying okay well maybe
they don't like my agenda because my
agenda is actually pretty radical left
for the time
instead there was this move toward well
perhaps the reason that this is
happening is because i'm black and the
media went right along with this the
idea was that if you attack barack obama
in any way it's because you were racist
the tea party was an outgrowth of racism
this is why there was that whole massive
controversy over whether john lewis had
been called a uh a an n-word and no tape
ever emerged of that and there was this
there were article after article the tea
party they're like terrorists all these
people who oppose barack obama are
really doing this because barack obama
is the first black president so
resistance to anything that he wants to
do is really a racially driven
resistance and then in 2012 you saw that
upped with with mitt romney being you
want to put you all back in chains our
current president said about mitt romney
the most milk toast human being ever to
walk the earth and and the the entire
campaign of 2012 was basically run along
if not overly intersectional lines
sort of i would say relatively
relatively over intersectional lines
there was an attempt to appeal to
particular racial groups specifically
and there were african-americans for
obama there were hispanic americans for
obama and and the idea was that
everybody would sort of
get an agenda item and these agenda
items would be cobbled together into a
coalition and you saw a lot of articles
around this time when obama won about
how there was this new coalition of the
dispossessed who were going to overwhelm
american politics when all brownstein
was writing about how democrats were
never going to lose an election again
there's this idea among democrats that
if they were able to cobble together an
intersectional coalition they'd never
lose again and and so obama because he
was so in his own person such a popular
president
and because he campaigned as post-racial
the the failure of that ideal in 2008
and the breakdown into polarization post
2008 i think led a lot of democrats to
believe okay well there really is a sort
of racial battle that's simmering under
the surface here even though pretty
explicitly the reason that barack obama
was elected in 2008 is because he was
going to be the first black president a
lot of people voted for barack obama in
the primaries who never would have voted
for a first-term junior senator from
illinois with no actual legislative
accomplishments on his record if he had
not been the first black super talented
politician yes but of course the the
nature of who he was led to his immense
popularity i mean people taking pictures
of themselves at the ballot box voting
for the first black it was supposed to
be the culmination of america's victory
over our horrific
record on race and instead and you can
see this in the polls
visions of how race was going in america
immediately began to turn you can see in
the polls that on race america
immediately started to hit the downs
down skids about 2009 2010. up to 2008
2009 the polls were really good in terms
of how many americans thought we were
getting closer in terms of race how many
americans thought we were doing well in
terms of race and then both white and
black americans after 2009-2010 you
start to see the polls really start to
dip pretty significantly
okay
that is
a very cogent political explanation and
and
i do think there's something
there about
democratic party strategy in terms of
how it's sort of cobbled together this
gu this coalition yes
my answer maybe is a little bit more
metaphysical
i believe that the surge of this and the
reason especially that so many young
people are drawn to it is crisis of
meaning and the death of god in this
country like i i just really believe
that
people are searching for some
moral purpose to their life the sense of
being part of a
of a
coalition of the righteous sense of
being on the right side of history
all of the things that we used to get
from other structures that because of
you know let's be honest like many of
the
fallouts of things like globalization
and tech and the rest you know that are
so much bigger than we have time for in
this conversation have led people sort
of grasping
for meaning i don't think the reason
that people are drawn to this ideology
in our generation younger is because
they're stupid
i really think it's you know
i think it's because it sort of lights
their soul on fire
in a real way
and
it sort of reminds me of just like any
religious revival movement at the
beginning which is like it light your
soul on fire and then you want to go
light other people on fire no i don't
think there's a mutually
i mean the explanation i'm giving is
sort of why it happened when it happened
but the explanation that you're giving
as to you know why it's happening at all
i think is of course the right
explanation i also think it has
something to do with the fact that if
you look at when these ideas sort of
started taking root in the academy it's
just around the time that you know
it's sort of us and and the kids about
five are kids the people five or ten
years younger than us who have only
marinated in this ideology when our
parents went to college i don't know if
your parents went to college
it was not the political monoculture
that it is now when i was in colombia
whatever it was now 15 years a million
years ago 15 years ago
this was it
right like like edward syed's
orientalism you know the idea that all
of the sort of maladies of the middle
east could be blamed on israel or
america that was the only idea that you
encountered in the middle east studies
department that was it and so you know
what look it turns out that ideas really
matter and that if you are only
marinating in a particular set of ideas
and you you don't even have the ability
to understand why someone would come to
a different set of conclusions because
you're literally never encountering it
well guess what like it turns out that
you make your way into the world and the
things that you learned about in the
gender studies department at oberlin or
the anthropology department of vassar
like those have shaped your mind and its
most important and impressionable years
and so why should we be surprised that
you know
people actually believe them and they
actually go into these companies and
change those companies in their image
the other thing i would add is you know
this is yuval levin id yuval levin's
idea not mine but the transformation of
these institutions into platforms
platforms on which it's a stage where we
all sort of play for our own benefit you
know and i'm as guilty of that as anyone
those are the incentives right now build
your audience bring your audience with
you well that's just transformationally
different you know than when you know 20
years ago before the internet was around
so i think all of those things sort of
have combined to bring us to to this
current moment okay so let's talk about
the the fact you're obviously very
openly jewish you're very openly
zionistic i'm
extremely openly jewish and openly
zionistic the yamaka says it all
but what that means is that i think for
for you uh the the aspect of the
intersectional movement that was pretty
obvious from the start was the
crossover with anti-semitism which is
which is really kind of surprising and
shocking if you're on the left and it's
it's not quite as shocking if you have
studied anything about anti-semitism in
the past where basically labeling of all
sorts of peoples always ends horribly
for the jews correct i mean first of all
in that sentence you could pretty much
supplant everything for the first half
of that sentence blank and then it ends
horribly for the jews but
what you wrote about in your book uh how
to fight anti-semitism
which was you know looked upon very
critically by members of the left is the
fact that there is
an unwillingness to look anti-semitism
in the face depending on your political
viewpoint you and i discussed this
before the book came out because we
talked about you coming on the show and
one of the things that i said is i think
that you're going to find that a lot of
people on the left are going to be angry
at you for for writing this book
specifically because you point out that
there is anti-semitism on the left and
if you want to fight anti-semitism you
actually have to look at anti-semitism
on the right and point it out and
anti-semitism on the left and pointed
out and you have to fight it wherever
you see it or you can't really claim to
be anti-anti-semitism
but that is that's an unpopular point of
view because there is a pretty strong
correlation between belief and
intersectionality and willingness to to
countenance anti-semitism yeah i mean
just
quick sort of like on one foot
explanation is that
jews are getting squeezed from both
extremes right now right so you know
better than probably anyone you know
what anti-semitism from the far right
looks like it looks like saying you know
jews pretend to be white people they
look like us they seem like us but in
fact you know they're they're loyal to
black people and brown people and
muslims and immigrants and in a sense
they're like the greatest trick the
devil has ever played and that was
certainly the ideology of the man that
walked into the synagogue where i began
bat mitzvah and killed as many jews as
he could and he specifically selected
that synagogue because the previous
shabbat the previous weekend it had
participated in refugee shabbat the idea
of you know welcoming the stranger and
biblical injunction to do so because we
ourselves are strangers in the land of
egypt that's the right and everyone
knows that because it's explicit we
don't need to have a talmudic debate
about like going on gab.com and saying
kill all the jews like we all see what
that is and because of course of you
know
because of course of hitler and the long
shadow of of
of the holocaust we all recognize it and
there's incredible clarity around it
and the trick with anti-semitism from
the left is that it comes cloaked in the
language of sort of justice and progress
and social justice and people are either
willing to be tricked by that or
genuinely are and what it says is sort
of the mirror image of the thing i just
expressed you and it all is in the
language of race because that's the
language of america right now and it
says you know
hold on you know the jews say that
they're victims did you say that they're
a minority but look at them look how
successful they are they benefit from
white privilege ralph lauren could
change his name from ralph liftgets to
ralph lauren and pass
you know and not only do they benefit
from white privilege and therefore
they're sort of adjacent to white
supremacy sort of holding up the
scaffolding for it they're also doubly
sinful because they are loyal to the
last standing bastion of white
colonialism in the middle east which is
the big lie that the soviet union told
about israel and that has now sort of
just made its way into mainstream
progressive culture and so the jews then
in their view of the world become guilty
of the two gravest sins
you know white supremacy white privilege
etc and colonialism and imperialism and
that's
the way i mean and that's what it is
right now and the thing that i just find
so incredible is that you have this
movement
that is you know made up of these
offense archaeologists who can go
searching you know for a for an
utterance that happened 20 years ago or
for you know a taco truck in portland
that's owned by people that aren't
actually hispanic you know and
you know there'll be dozens of stories
written about that online campaign
change.org and then jews will get hacked
up by a machete and they'll have nothing
to say about it
so that's what you need to know you
don't need to understand you know all of
the ins and outs of this ideology this
is what they like to do they pretend
they play these semantic games or they
tell you you need to have a law degree
or you've had to read these 10 books by
these theories to understand it no you
just have to see things with your eyes
and ears and a movement that has more
rage
about you know
using the word jedi or saying the phrase
pregnant women than they do for jews
getting literally beaten
in neighborhoods like borough park and
crown heights that tells you everything
you need to know about its priorities
yeah the democratic party and the
republican party obviously is is more
political than we've been throughout
this conversation um but it seems as
though the democratic party has really
drunken from a lot of this well and we
saw for example that the the democratic
party they had to pass a separate bill
in order to pass for example iron dome
funding rashida talib and nohan omar
have only recently has anybody in the
democratic party actually have the
stones to stand up and say it was ted
deutsch from actually this district but
it took a year and a half for anybody in
the democratic party to point out the
obvious which is that illinois and
rashid tulip are not fond of the jews um
not that that wasn't obvious yeah
exactly but but you know in the same way
that that steve king had to be written
out of congress on rail by the
republican party uh ilhan omar is still
sitting on the foreign affairs committee
of the of the house right now yeah
although marjorie taylor green's still
in there with her jewish space laser
commandments but yeah she is i i will
say that marjorie taylor green at least
had the
sense to go to the holocaust museum and
mouth some some words about it uh which
you really have not gotten from from
ilhan omar at this point and believe me
that's no defense of marjorie taylor
green the the point being that if you're
looking at where the anti-semitism is
more mainstream in the parties it seems
as though it's being mainstreamed more
into the democratic party at this point
i'm wondering if you think that there's
going to be any pushback to that because
it seems like the younger breed of
democrats are much more willing to move
along with
pretty openly anti-semitic stuff than
the older democrats the older democrats
are still doing what older democrats
have historically done which is they're
more moderate on israel they're still
calling for concessions from israel's
the palestinians all that sort of thing
but it's the same dynamic that that it's
the exact same dynamic we were talking
about before with you know the publisher
of the new york times right is he the
publisher is he in charge or is nicole
hannah jones actually in charge of the
new york times that's the question and
it's like chuck schumer and nancy pelosi
they're supposed to be in charge of the
party so why is it that you know it
seems to most of us watching that the
actual people in charge are aoc and
ayanna presley and ilhan omar it's the
exact same dynamic playing out
everywhere
so when i saw ted deutsch you know stand
up to it i was like wow this is this is
shocking only because you've seen just
utter capitulation
i mean during the last war with gaza i
think
you saw you saw like you know one
sentence press release or like the
choking out of like the tiniest defense
of israel in a facebook post by some of
these people who are sensibly supposed
to be in charge
i think a lot of the institutionalized
anti-semitism i think a lot of the
anti-semitism that's you know acceptable
in you know elite upper crust
intellectual circles there's no question
that's coming from the left but the
gutter anti-semitism you know the kind
of anti-semitism that you know leads
people to send me really crazy letters
or you know in the case of when i used
to live in new york like call my rabbi
and you know threaten us that's often
coming from the right the physical
terror the physical anti-semitism the
violence that's coming from the right
the anti-semitism that's sort of
socially or politically acceptable
that's coming from the left and the
whole thing is that you have to be
fighting both and i think one of the
sort of the tests is if you're serious
about actually fighting jew hate and
you're on the right you've got to be
calling it out in your own house you got
to be calling it out on the right and if
you're serious about it on the left you
have to be calling it out from the left
and i think so often what we're seeing
is people sort of using you know fake
care about the jews as a kind of
political cudgel in order to beat the
other side over the head so
we were talking before the show a little
bit about you know our kind of great
fears for the country because you and i
differ on a lot of policy prescriptions
in fact i think that we we may differ on
more than we agree on in terms of actual
in actual policy we may be on the same
page on some foreign policy matters but
on domestic policy matters you're much
more of a government should be involved
in spending initiatives person you're
much more socially liberal than i am on
virtually all the issues that you
mentioned earlier but we we definitely
agree on sort of the under the iceberg
issues which are do we get to talk
freely to one another should we have
conversations about this should there be
a level of subsidiarity in the united
states should there be due process
should people be judged based on the
sins of their parents i mean those small
issues right exactly and and so i i
guess that my great fear that we were
discussing earlier is whether
that center is is going to hold which is
sort of the core of the entire
conversation because what what i'm
seeing in politics right now is this
reactionary ping-ponging where the left
goes really far left and so the right
very often will just react by saying
okay well you know what if you're going
to use the ring of power this way well
when i get the ring of power i'm
definitely not throwing into mount doom
i'm going to use the ring of power and
i'm going to smack you so hard it's
going to make your head spin and the
idea is that if you don't smack them so
hard that their head spins they won't
they won't stop like
we are we're beyond the point of talking
or beyond the point of being able to
live together in the country and i i
wonder how much of that is very online
but i also wonder how much of that's
going to bleed down because there's this
feeling you know you're on twitter a lot
i'm on twitter a lot and and there is
the saying that you know don't get too
into the twitter bubble right don't
don't believe that twitter is real life
but it is that but that's kind of the
thing right they used to say the same
thing about college campuses i wrote my
very first book which i wrote in 2003 so
i would have been 19. yeah i was 19 when
i wrote it it came out when i was when i
was 20. and that book which was about
bias on college campuses and some of the
stuff happening on college campuses i
remember the number one question i got
is who cares why it's happening on
college campuses and the same thing is
happening on twitter
as people start to
er the two most live wires kind of in in
politics on twitter right now are the
hard left the kind of woke squad left
and the nationalist populist the
nationals populist right and it seems
like everybody who's sort of in between
is is being categorized as as a squish
in some way and so i'm i'm wondering how
you think what do you think is the best
way to
this is the number one thing that i
think about and i mean for me it's
pretty simple the way that you push back
against it is by not succumbing to it
the way you push back against it is by
saying i refuse to make that choice the
way you push back against it is by doing
sort of exactly what we're doing right
now and what i'm trying to do with my
podcast and my newsletter it's just
calling calling out the balls and
strikes as you see them telling the
truth
being willing frankly to piss off your
audience you know the problem of
audience capture is definitely not
something that's been solved the new
york times to come to it but everyone
succumbs to it
you know that's that's the nature of
where we live and i knew the other day
that you know i published this sort of
um forum on the question of vaccine
mandates and it contained you know two
lightning rods glenn greenwald and
adrian vermeuel and you better believe i
lost a lot of paying subscribers that
day from both perspectives and i thought
to myself you know what that's okay like
that's kind of what i need to be
modeling is i need to be
showing people in my own life in the way
i conduct myself in the media company
that hopefully i'll i'm building you
know that that it is possible and the
way to do it starts by modeling it i
think that's really important so you've
made a lot of life changes over the past
few years the new york times
you got married uh you moved locations
and now you're thinking about moving
locations again so how are you building
that we talked a little bit about like
building the kind of
life that you need to build right with
the support structure but allowing a
sort of feedback loop to change your
mind on things yeah how are you thinking
about constructing that sort of life
first of all i always i'm going to be
grateful for to the new york times
because that's where i met my wife who
has subsequently also left although
she's much classier than i am so she's
done it in a much quieter subtler way
but she's helping me as we build this
company and look i would say that
judaism has been a huge anchor in my
life and increasingly so there was a
period of my life when i was in college
and then afterward where i was pretty
religious you know keeping shabbat
keeping kosher and everything and then i
kind of moved away from it and now i
would say we're definitely moving back
in that direction i think that you know
being anchored in community hosting
shabbat dinner or going to one every
single friday night trying very hard to
get totally offline for 25 hours
being deeply connected with my
incredible family in pittsburgh and huge
extended family will probably end up
there at some point these are the things
that ultimately make a life these are
the things that make being in public and
being disliked and kind of hearing the
noise without letting it penetrate your
soul that's what makes it possible
and i just don't think that there's a
way to do it and get sort of buffeted by
it without having that anchoring without
having that mooring definitely want to
start a family i mean
i want to have a balanced good life and
i
you know i feel extremely extremely
extremely lucky
that i feel like i've sort of
born into that
continuing to build that and and really
being able to be free genuinely um in
this in what i'm doing with my writing
and what i'm doing with the kind of
people that i'm trying to elevate i
really believe that you know if glenn
lowry and john mccorder were as famous
as ibrahim kennedy you know if chloe
valdari were as famous as nicole hannah
jones if you know there's lots of young
people i'm talking to all the time but
if they had the kind of sway over the
culture that some of these other people
have we would be in a really different
place and so that's what i'm really
really focused on trying to do so i
actually want to ask you about what you
think is the future of what you're doing
because it is a growing enterprise you
obviously have a big audience and it's
going to get bigger so i want to talk to
you about that in just one second first
if you want to hear barry weiss's
answers you have to be a daily wire
member go to dailywire.com click
subscribe you can hear the rest of our
conversation over there barry can't wait
to see what you build next everyone make
sure check out barry's new podcast
honestly with barry weiss it is worth
the lesson and her sub stack common
sense with barry weiss barry thanks so
much for joining us thanks ben
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday's special is
produced by mathis glover executive
producer jeremy boring and our assistant
director is pavel wydowsky our guests
are booked by caitlin maynard editing is
by jim nicholl audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina title graphics are by cynthia
angulo the ben shapiro show sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]